for months now russia has demanded
negotiations with the west down the
barrel of a gun bringing ever more
troops to its border with ukraine
supposedly for exercises and currently
joint drills with the belarusian armed
forces
and now to the country's strategic
deterrence forces on display in other
words nuclear drills a massive show of
strength from the world's largest
nuclear power
these are short-range iskandar cruise
missiles nuclear-capable ground-launched
and frighteningly accurate
and the air-launched kinsale hypersonic
cruise missile which can also carry
nuclear warheads with russia leading the
way in hypersonic missile technology
the commander-in-chief vladimir putin
and his belarusian counterpart watched
on a giant screen in the kremlin
situation room and with russia's full
capabilities on display are these huge
nuclear drills brought forward and
announced publicly only yesterday an
illustration that russia's calculus has
changed and that invasion is decided on
as the u.s president says and russia
denies
the signs from the separatist republics
in eastern ukraine are not good women
children and the elderly told to leave
by the russian-backed separatist leaders
who claim it is for their own protection
against what they call ukrainian acts of
sabotage and terror
do these people know they're being used
evacuated for the cameras for the
russian public back home
willfully separated from families and
from their homes by a foreign power to
illustrate a threat which does not exist
but which russia can use as a pretext
for war
ukraine says they have no intention to
escalate and why would they with so many
russian troops on their border
russia now claims shells supposedly from
ukrainian forces have landed in their
territory the ukrainians deny it they've
in turn released video of one of their
checkpoints coming under fire there's
clearly escalation and only one side
whose purpose it serves
and then this from the separatist
leaders in donbass
we should unite all our efforts i call
on my fellow countrymen reservists to
report to mobilization offices today i
have signed a decree on general
mobilization i call on all men in the
republic able to hold a weapon in their
hands to stand up to protect your
families your children wives and mothers
the u.s defense secretary on a tour of
the baltic states today to reaffirm u.s
support for countries on nato's eastern
flank and to remind vladimir putin that
the door is still open for dialogue the
united states
in lockstep with our allies and partner
partners have offered him
an opportunity to pursue a diplomatic
solution
we hope that he takes it
these drills with belarus end on sunday
it will take some time for the tanks to
withdraw
but if invasion is decided on they can
move fast the other way dana magnay sky
news moscow